يمكن أن تظهر دراسة صغيرة بعض
الوعود الكبيرة عندما يتعلق الأمر بمساعدتك على خفض
السعرات الحرارية ، كل ذلك يعود إلى كيفية تصنيف
المنتجات الغذائية وفقًا
لبحث نُشر في مجلة
علم الأوبئة وملصقات طعام صحة المجتمع
التي توضح مقدار النشاط
المطلوب للحرق.
يمكن أن تؤدي السعرات الحرارية من ما تأكله إلى خيارات صحية أكثر
من ملصقات التغذية العادية ،
على سبيل المثال ، النشاط البدني
الملصقات المعادلة للسعرات الحرارية التي تسمى عادةً
ملصقات اللصق ، ستدرج على لوح من
الشوكولاتة يستغرق 23 دقيقة من الجري أو
46 دقيقة من المشي حتى تحترق
يقول الباحثون أن الحلوى التي تحتوي على 230 سعرًا حراريًا
قد تساعد المستهلكين على خفض
متوسط 200 سعر حراري يوميًا من نظامهم الغذائي ، حيث قا
ت المجموعة بسحب البيانات من 14 در
سة أخرى بحثت في فعالية وض
العلامات على السرعة وخفض السعرات الحرارية بي
ما حذر الباحثون من أن ال
راسات كانت صغيرة و  لم يتم
تنفيذها في ظروف الحياة الواقعية ، فهي
تبشر بالخير لتقليل استهلاك السعرات الحرارية
تقول الباحثة إن الهدف هو
الحصول على كلتا المجموعتين من المنتجات الغذائية
والقوائم لإعطاء الجمهور أكبر
قدر ممكن من المعلومات في
الدقيقة الصحية اليوم أنا ماري مولوني